autant j'ai cette union européenne trois
sommets dans la même journée à bruxelles
pour un même objectif comment stopper
vladimir poutine sans entrer en guerre
avec la russie avant d'en débattre avec
mes invités les enjeux et les obstacles
de ce triptyque diplomatiques avec
marion guillot un mois jour pour jour
après l'invasion de l'ukraine par la
russie une intense journée diplomatique
s'ouvre ce jeudi à bruxelles première
étape la réunion des 30 membres de
l'otan pour coordonner les actions et
renforcer leurs positions à l'est quatre
nouveaux bataillons vont être déployés
en roumanie hongrie bulgarie et
slovaquie quant aux quarante mille
troupes déjà présentes elles seront ré
équiper
comment john rod notre commandant
militaire le général walters a activé
les éléments de défense chimiques
biologiques radiologiques et nucléaires
de l'otan de france à la vente
et les alliés déploie des moyens
supplémentaires pour renforcer nos
groupements tactiques existants et
nouveaux
formats existants un nul pas terrible
des équipements qui seront également
transmis à l'ukraine présent aux
visioconférences le président et nine
ski à lui renouvelé sa demande d' aide
militaire des consultations commencent
pour lui fournir des missiles
antinavires dans l'après-midi ce sont
les membres du g7 qui se sont ensuite
réunies pour envisager de nouvelles
sanctions économiques envers la russie
ils veulent cette fois ci viser les
députés de la douma et les industries de
défense et notre détermination nous a
conduits à prendre un train de sanctions
absolument inédit à l'unisson
l'économie russe est d'ailleurs au
moment où je vous parle en cessation de
paiement sa monnaie a dévissé son
isolement est croissant et notre
pression il y aura s'accentuant en
cherchant là aussi
par tous les moyens d'obtenir un cessez
le feu et la paix dernière étape le
conseil européen des 27 toujours en
présence du président américain joe
biden pour évoquer la gestion et la
répartition des réfugiés mais aussi la
crise alimentaire à venir tout au long
de cette journée les objectifs ayant été
d'afficher une unité sans faille et
d'anticiper les étapes à venir en cas d'
escalade russe
l'occident fait bloc voilà le thème de
notre débat et vous présente mes invités
tout de suite wihr fabry bonsoir bien si
vous êtes chercheuse senior à l'institut
jacques delors en charge la politique
commerciale de l'union européenne et de
la mondialisation et vous venez de
publier avec l'institut un rapport sur
l'autonomie stratégique de l'europe face
à la chine christian lequesne bonsoir
bonsoir mieux vaut si vous êtes
professeur à sciences po paris à hauteur
de la puissance par l'image les états et
leur diplomatie publique cette aux
presses de sciences po avec nous en
visioconférence christian ma carrière
bonsoir merci accepté au débotté on va
le dire notre invitation christian vous
êtes journaliste au point et à radio
notre-dame et ont fait un coucou à
françois durpaire voilà qui nous a fait
faux bond à lallaing minutes mais
c'était vraiment repas de sa volonté on
lui souhaite bon courage laetitia cru
pas évidemment toujours à mes côtés à
lemé côté dans ce dans ce débat on a
choisi ce titre l'occident fait bloc est
ce que c'est le symbole que vous
associer à cette journée vous aussi ou
pas d'ailleurs oui tout à fait je crois
que ce que l'on voit d'abord c'est que
c'est un exercice de d'affichage de
solidarité de cohésion à la fois qui
envoie un message à la fois en interne
dans les équipes parce que c'est
important que les chefs d'état de
gouvernement se retrouvent entre eux
c'est un message qui est envoyé
évidemment à l'ukraine de soutiens
évidemment à la russie et puis et puis
plus loin quand même aussi à la chine
on va revenir là dessus et au et au
reste du monde parce qu'il ya toute une
série de pays qui sont quand même
silencieux qui prennent une position
plus neutre et là c'est un cetain c'est
un bloc à la fois avec cette imbrication
de l'otan du g7 et puis maintenant des
27 on voit que c'est finalement tout un
dispositif à plusieurs étages qui montre
toute sa cohérence une déclaration de
joe biden en cette fin d'après midi
l'otan n'a jamais été aussi unis
christian lequel est ce que est ce que
ce bloc occidental est aussi solide
qu'il en a l'air
oui alors le bloc occidental il a bien
sûr des nuances et d'abord il faut il
faut quand même saluer le fait que le
président américain accepte de se
déplacer en europe je trouve que
symboliquement c'est important et ça
donne l'impression que l'europe n'a pas
été oubliée comme priorités stratégiques
alors que depuis pas mal
la présidence obama on avait le
sentiment que dans la liste des
priorités américaines l'europe c'était
vraiment paroisse était plutôt vers le
bas il y avait la question chinoise qui
est de vie reconnaît bien il y avait le
moyen-orient voilà maintenant face
aux américains ce qu'il serait
souhaitable c'est que l'europe souhaite
unis on est je crois que dans le fond
c'est ce que les américains
souhaiteraient aussi
et notre notre crédibilité à l'égard des
américains passent par notre capacité
nous européens à être unis dans le camp
dans le camp occidental
on est sur cette question là bas nous
savons qu'ils bien encore des nuances on
pourra en parler on va en parler
évidemment et on voit déjà les les
lignes de fracture qui commença à
s'exprimer christian makarian que qu'est
ce que vous retenez vous de de cette
journée au delà du symbole c'est
effectivement un symbole fort on a un
job hayden qui vient qui participa à
trois sommets successifs on peut dire
d'ailleurs que c'est il ya là un défi
pour un homme de 69 ans de 79 ans pas le
plus important mais au delà du symbole
qu'est ce que vous retenez
écouté il est obligé d'effectuer une
pirouette stratégique
tout à fait crucial et il le fait
jusqu'ici de façon assez habile il ya
deux facteurs qu'il faut appeler la
ligne directrice de la politique
étrangère américaine
c'est toujours le fameux pivote le pivot
d'obama c'est à dire se tourner vers
l'asie comme le point à la fois
d'importance économique primordial mais
aussi le point de friction et de tension
maximale avec des questions comme celle
par exemple de deux de taïwan au de la
chine deux mers du sud rock cette espèce
de priorisation à la chine qui avait été
faite par obama poursuivi par trump est
prolongé par biden qui a tout de même
été deux fois le vice président d'obama
oblige aujourd'hui by dell à remettre
l'europe au centre des tensions
mondiales avec un conflit qui semble
appartenir à une autre époque en turban
d'un homme de la guerre froide il a été
élu sénateur en 1973 rendez compte en
plein milieu de la guerre froide et il a
accompagné toute cette période
plus d'un demi siècle d'évolution et de
relations avec la russie qui est un pays
qui connaît bien où il s'est rendu de
nombreuses fois puisqu'il était aux
affaires étran la commission des
affaires étrangères du sénat c'est même
pour cela qu'obama l'a pris comme
vice-président parce qu'ils avaient une
expérience de politique étrangère
qu'obama n'avait pas de rui binder est
en train d'opérer un virage sur l'ale
très important pour prioriser l'europe
et jusqu'ici il le fait bien mis un
aspect intérieur et je terminerai avec
ça qui est très important c'est qu'il ya
un consensus comme il n'a jamais eu sous
le mandat de bailleul entre républicains
et démocrates sur la fermeté absolue
adopter face à la russie donc je ride
elle joue aussi une partie de politique
intérieure à travers cette espèce de
fermeté et de réconciliation avec
l'europe et je crois que c'est important
de le signaler du reste ce qui lui est
reproché par les républicains c'est
quelque chose de tout à fait essentiel
et âmes et les traits qu'on en parle
tous ensemble tout à l'heure c'est que
dès le début du conflit il a dit de
façon très maladroite que les etats-unis
né à thann interviendrait pas
militairement ce qui était une manière
de laisser le champ libre à poutine
non pas parce que poutine n'attendais
que ça et qu'il craignait les états unis
parce que ça mais parce que ça a laissé
le champ libre à la notion de guerre
totale à laquelle poutine se livre
devant nos yeux on y reviendra
évidemment donc il ya d'une certaine
façon naturellement dans notre débat et
en trois chapitres
pour trois sommets autant j'ai cette
union européenne je commence par l'otan
on va faire un peu de pédagogie auto
également organisation du traité de
l'atlantique nord c'est pas inutile de
rappeler ce que ça veut dire puisque
certains candidats en l'occurrence une
candidate ne savais plus ce que c'était
créée peu après la seconde guerre
mondiale 1949 30 états membres au budget
total d'un peu plus de 2,5 milliards
d'euros et un secrétaire général
norvégien jens stoltenberg
qui vient c'était aujourd'hui d'annoncer
un renforcement militaire on écoute les
deux sacs l'oms les dirigeants ont
approuvé la création de quatre nouveaux
groupements tactiques en bulgarie en
hongrie en roumanie et en slovaquie a
souvent qu'un
en plus des quatre déjà constituées dans
les trois pays baltes et en pologne
nous avons donc huit groupements
tactiques de l'otan à présent la mer
baltique à la mer noire fronde un bon
texte études à
l'accident qui a également rappelé que
la russie vladimir poutine voulait -
d'autant à ses frontières vont mal c'est
raté oui c'est raté parce que là on voit
que l'otan des places des capacités pour
sécuriser ce qui pourrait être en tout
cas le territoire des états membres de
l'otan qui sont le plus sur la sur la
ligne de front par ailleurs on a quand
même des états membres de l'union
européenne qui ne font pas partie de
l'otan traditionnellement de longue date
et qui ceux qui ont déjà évoqué la
volonté éventuellement de rejoindre le
temps qu'ils sont la finlande et de la
suède ils l'ont à des pays qui à la
porte de l'otan presse plus fortement
pour rentrer plus rapidement dans l'otan
la géorgie et la moldavie qui se sentent
plus directement menacé donc finalement
l'objectif initial de poutine qui était
en effet de deux repoussées l'otan à
contribuer au contraire aujourd'hui à
redynamiser la structure à renforcer la
solidarité entre les états une question
ça prend combien de temps par exemple
pour la moldavie pour la géorgie de les
intégrer il ya un process qui dure
combien de temps ce serait d'abord une
question de décisions politiques si je
puis dire parce que si
ensuite cédé je dirais qu ensuite cédé
il ya des engagements qui sont pris sur
la durée elle même je pourrais je serai
pas en mesure de vous dire mais sur le
syli a des idées ça se prépare comme
toujours c'est des questions de capacité
qu'on met à disposition de la deûle
plusieurs mois sur le quai oui
habituellement c'est ici on prend les
derniers élargissements c'est plus
rapide que l'entrée dans l'union
européenne ce que j'avais
l'entrée dans l'union européenne ça
nécessite aux réformes et à peu près
toutes les législations nationales
ce critère qui qu'actuellement d'eau que
je partage l'idée que c'est une c'est
une décision politique qui peut les
assez vite d'ailleurs on peut rappeler
que le sommet de bucarest 2008 avait
fixé le principe de l'entrée de
l'ukraine et de la géorgie mais
qu'ensuite voilà on a pas on n'a pas
continuer le processus notamment parce
que les grands pays européens n'y tenais
pas alors laëtitia s'est depuis le début
de cette guerre en ukraine depuis un
mois on a vu beaucoup de deux certitudes
stratégie parfois vieilles de plusieurs
décennies volé en éclats et puis à une
déclaration celle d'un certain emmanuel
macron sur l'otan qui elle aussi semble
totalement je sais pas
antidaté ringardisé sais pas quel terme
employer oui enfin en tout cas il n'est
jamais revenu dessus ni même aujourd'hui
on va le voir tout de suite mais c'est
effectivement une déclaration qu'il a
eue en novembre 2019 dans une interview
au journal die économistes emmanuel
macron président de la france avait
déclaré ce qu'on est en train de vivre
c'est la mort cérébrale de l'otan salués
resté à sète mais alors on est dans quel
contexte il réagissait à l'offensive en
fait du président turc erdogan qui avait
lancé donc cette offensive dans le
nord-est de la syrie sans aucune
concertation avec les alliés et je
rappelle que la turquie fait partie de
l'otan et à cette époque les soldats
américains s'étaient retirés aussi de la
région si vous voulez pour emmanuel
macron il s'agissait c'était plutôt a
tenté de réveiller cette cette
organisation il ne l'enterrerai pas il
voulait la réveiller et puis il y avait
aussi des craintes en avaient peur par
exemple que donald trump soit réélu et
décide d'un tweet de quitter l'otan donc
on était dans un contexte qui était
absolument différent de celui
d'aujourd'hui et comme je vous le disais
tout à l'heure il n'est jamais revenu
sur ses propos d'ailleurs il l'a dit lui
même aujourd'hui parce qu'il utilise une
autre formule ecoutez-le
l'otan
vient d'avoir un électrochoc moi qui
parlais de mort cérébrale en décembre
2019 l'électrochoc c'est que la
confidentialité à ses frontières est
revenu puisque la guerre a été lancée
par la russie pas contraintes de nos
membres mais contre un voisin proche
et l'objectif d' emmanuel macron est le
même qu'en 2019 il s'agit de débuter
enfin les fondations de mettre les
premières pierres de la défense
européenne en 2019 comme aujourd'hui on
sait encore balbutiant mais peut-être
que la guerre en ukraine may précipité
ce processus a fait partie des
changements de pied des certitudes dont
dont on parlait tout à l'heure puisqu'on
l'a déjà évoqué sur ce plateau
l'allemagne a totalement sur les
stratégies notamment sur son budget
militaire là christian makarian quel est
le poids de la france dans l'otan ce
qu'on réagit à fait à cette déclaration
ancien des mâles macron et est ce que le
poids dépend toujours de la halle
comment dire de la lourdeur du chèque ou
est ce que veut dire
voilà l'odeur du chèque c'est le
reproche qui a été adressé par donald
trump à tous les dirigeants européens en
leur demandant d' atteindre un montant
du pib qui soit plus significatives
au-dessus de 2% le bo la plupart des
pays était dans le flou notamment un
grand pays un des plus riches du monde
qui s'appelle l'allemagne la france n'y
était pas non plus mais on a promis d'y
arriver donc on va y arriver parce qu'il
faut rappeler une donnée essentielle à
peu près soixante dix pour cent du
budget de l'otan est assumé par les
états unis sur les trente nations que
compte l'otan donc que les américains
soient un peu agacé ça paraît pas
spécifiquement anormal mais maintenant
la façon dont ces cris dossier prix
donateur était tout de même très brutal
d'autant qu'il a mis en balance
l'article 5 qui est le plus important
qui prévoit l'entrée d'une mutuelle en
cas l'agression contre un état trump a
laissé entendre un moment que cet
article ne serait plus fonctionnel alors
là c'était la menace absolue de
dissolution de l'otan donc entre train
et ses menaces entre la phrase
d'emmanuel mâcon qui a beau essayer de
faire une pirouette m'enfin il a quand
même dit état de mort cérébrale il a dit
on rend les cours que l'otan et le
bouclier unique et que c'est celui qui
rassure les pays européens et il n'est
pas étonnant mais toute la polémique
porte sur ça que les pays de l'est et
souhaitez le rejoindre en deux vagues
principal en 1999 puis en 2004 parce que
justement ces pays se sentait
insécurisés menacé par la russie donc à
la russie dit que en élargissant l'otan
à l'est on a quelque part adresser la
russie un contre argument consiste à
dire tout simplement que si les pays
d'europe centrale s'étaient sentis en
sécurité
il n'aurait jamais demandé à ce point là
un joindre l'otan alors la question qui
est vraiment une question d'actualité
aujourd'hui c'est jusqu'où peut aller le
l'engagement la réponse de l'otan on a
entendu tout à l'heure le secrétaire
général a annoncé un déploiement plus
important de troupes d'ailleurs est mal
macron dans sa conférence de presse a
détaillé un peu où les soldats français
puisque certains soldats français vont
se redéployer aussi il ya cette ligne
rouge en quelque sorte qui a été posée
par le président américain joe biden il
promet une réponse de l'otan si la
russie utilise des armes syrie chimiques
ont on a des souvenirs d'autres ligne
rouge posée par d'autres présidents
américains dans dans le passé qui voilà
qui finalement ont plutôt été des freins
ou des boulets ensuite dans leurs
diplomaties donc comment vous percevez
7,7 déclarations de joe biden se soient
écoutés c'est la première ligne rouge
d'une certaine pression qui est affiché
et je pense que c'est aussi une façon de
de réaffirmer
la cohésion des membres de l'otan qui
encore une fois là sont dans une
démarche de réassurance sur la sécurité
du territoire européen dans son ensemble
ils se sont donnés une clause de rendez
vous déjà pour le mois de juin pour par
les investissements stratégie de
sécurité à l'échelle de l'union
européenne
et là c'est le planche s'il veut dire un
peu de de réorganisation de l'otan où il
s'agit de deux ça y est on est passé
dans une deuxième phase maintenant sur
cette question de lignes rouges
comme ça vient d'être appelé lorsque
président biden a annoncé qu'il
n'enverrait pas d'homme
sur le continent européen
ça avait d'une certaine façon ouvert
savait donner un champ libre plus plus
de marge de manoeuvre à plat dit à
vladimir poutine maintenant on voit que
c'est une là il ya un risque qui est
quand même imminent ce que le secrétaire
général de l'otan a dit cet après midi
c'est qu'ils avaient quand même des
informations tangibles sur l'utilisation
déjà deux bombes au phosphore ils sont
très inquiets et la non là c'est un
engagement qui est beaucoup plus ferme
mais mais christian lequesne
effectivement quand on pose une ligne
rouge qu'est ce qu'on fait ensuite si
elle est franchie qu'en encore joe by
owdi jeu promet une réponse de l'otan
bon c'est assez vague encore mais quel
poète la réponse alors devenir que les
comédies gérant emmanuel macron la
rappeler ces sirops nous ne souhaitons
pas devenir co belligérants alors la
ligne actuellement c'est ça c'est à dire
on ne veut pas être qu aux belligérants
aux changes ou on ne veut pas engager de
moyens défensif et là c'est tout le tout
le problème
que posent les demandes de zelensky
puisque nm ce qui demande des chars
demande des avions de chasse vous savez
qui s'exprime régulièrement
dans l'est dans les parlements par
vidéoconférence thierry s'est exprimé à
l'assemblée nationale et au sénat en
france voilà ça on ne veut pas c'est à
dire on veut rester sur des livraisons
d'armes défensives ceci étant ce n'est
pas la même chose de dire nous ne
voulons pas être qu aux belligérants et
nous n'interviendrons pas militairement
envoyer ses pattes c'est pas le même
discours et là je suis d'accord avec
christian makarian l'erreur de biden au
début a été de dire nous ne voulons pas
d'intervention militaire il faut il faut
rester sur cette ligne nous ne voulons
pas être des co belligérants pour garder
quand même une incertitude pourquoi
c'est parce que
c'est très subtil mais tout simplement
parce que poutine joue sur l'ambiguïté
et les dictateurs adore l'ambiguïté donc
face à ça il faut aussi que nous soyons
ambiguë alors vous avez évoqué la
demande du le président ukrainien
wladimir zelensky effectivement il dit à
l'otan vous avez vingt mille chars on en
veut un tout petit peu écouté le
vous avez au moins vingt mille chars
l'ukraine a demandé qu'un pourcent 1% de
tous vos chars nous soit donnée ou
vendue d'athéna
mais nous n'avons pas encore de réponse
claire
la pire chose pendant la guerre et de ne
pas avoir de réponse claire aux demandes
dead
christian makarian ça veut dire 200
chars je voudrais juste comprendre
pourquoi c'est un pas que
[Musique]
l'otan ne veut pas franchir pour
l'instant mais parce que ce que demande
monsieur zelensky c'est des conditions
d'un pays adhérant sans qu'ils adhèrent
ce n'est pas possible
si l'otan avait incorporé l'ukraine la
russie ne se serait peut-être pas
comporter comme elle l'a fait 7 c'est
une une hypothèse en tout cas qu'on peut
prendre sérieusement en considération
mais en tout cas puisque
l'ukraine ne fait pas partie de l'otan
toutes interventions offensives tous
types d'armements agressif permettant de
détruire des forces russes du matériel
russe et du personnel russe constitue un
acte de guerre et nous entraînerait là
dedans il ya eu un cas très intéressant
posés par la pologne la pologne dispose
d'anciens 100 avions soviétique de type
milk que les pilotes ukrainiens qui ont
aussi des mig savent parfaitement manier
la pologne a donc proposé de prêter ses
amis non de les apporter
dans l'aéroport à côté de l'ofs pour que
les pilotes ukrainiens en disposent et
malheureusement là aussi avec une
certaine rigueur mais avec une certaine
maladresse au lieu de faire ça
secrètement ça a été rendu public et on
a demandé l'autorisation aux états unis
de faire ce transport de ce transfert
d'avion de pologne vers l'ukraine les
etats unis s'y sont opposés parce que
l'idée est véritablement irrecevable ce
serait un acte de guerre vous voyez donc
pareil pour les missiles
sol mer on pourrait envoyer des missiles
sol mer en ukraine enfin il faudrait
déjà arrivé à les acheminer mais
supposons qu on y arrive qui tirait sur
les bateaux russes mais les russes et
les identifierez tout de suite comme
étant des missiles occidentaux mais et
donc voilà c'est la scala j'entends bien
mais justement
fabriès que c'est pas finalement la
seule solution est ce que le langage de
la force n'est pas le seul langage que
vladimir poutine en temps est ce qu ont
dépassé pour la première fois qu'on
évoque sa mais dans ce dans ce moment un
peu munichois qui fait qu'on devrait
intervenir militairement il n'y a pas
d'autre solution n'est certain oui en
même temps cette logique de non escalade
elle est essentielle puisque l'on voit
qu'on voit très bien ce qu on voit très
bien dans la façon dont la dîmière
poutine même joue avec la menace d'al
usage d'armes tactiques nucléaires de
missiles nucléaires enfin le cette
escalade
elle est irréversible là pour le coup
c'est quelque chose qui si on franchit
ciel pas qui est qui met la stratégie
actuelle elle se fait au détriment du
peuple ukrainien
oui mais là tout cela est le seul à
combattre il me dire moi j'ai un de mes
amis j'ai pardon de vous faire c'est
très personnel mais qui me disait ah moi
j'ai honte j'ai compte que mon pays que
l'europe que l'otan n'intervienne pas
militairement c'est pour ça que le
soutien en armement et
renforcer le soutien humanitaire et
renforcer le soutien également en un
provisionnement et renforcé parce que
l'on voit c'est un autre terrain mais on
voit déjà que il ya de tels problèmes
d'approvisionnement même en essence que
toute l'agriculture ukrainienne est déjà
en train de s'effondrer là où elle
pourrait quand même continuer encore
dans certaines régions de l'ukraine et
qu'il ya des problèmes de d'alimentation
qui vont se poser enfin qui vont
s'ajouter encore au problème il m'a dit
'je à ce que la question en fait j'ai
absent que personne n'a répondu à votre
question tomassi la russie utilise une
arme chimique quelle sera la réponse de
l'otan
concrètement
peut-être que la réponse est difficile
je pense que là la réponse
n'ira pas jusqu'à un engagement un
engagement militaire je n'y crois pas je
pense que personne ne veut du côté de
l'ouest et ça aussi bien aux états unis
qu'en europe part peut-être les polonais
est encore
entré dans le entrer dans le conflit
mais ça ne veut pas dire qu'on ne
soutient pas militairement et c'est ça
le point le point important et vous
voyez l'exemple qui a été cité sur les
sur les avions si vous livrer des mig
que vous repeignez aux couleurs de
l'ukraine évidemment c'est très visible
et ça peut immédiatement prêté le flanc
à une interprétation de la part des
russes qui est vous entrez dans le
conflit en revanche si vous livrer des
drones c'est beaucoup plus discret
c'est tout aussi tout aussi efficace et
ça sert peut-être même mieux l'armer
l'armée ukrainienne oui il faut faire
attention faut faire attention justement
à ne pas prêter le flanc à une
interprétation de poutine qui
consisterait à dire ça y est vous êtes
vous êtes belligérants donner la parole
mais juste citation de joe bayonne
toujours sur cette thématique des armes
chimiques je suis pas sûr que ça éclaire
totalement le débat midi la nature de la
réponse de l'otan dépendant de la nature
de l'utilisation des armes chimiques par
par la russie bref on se sera une
réponse graduée quoi c'est ce qu'on peut
comprendre je pense qu'au delà de la
question de la réponse même de l'otan il
ya la façon dont l'enjeu de
l'utilisation des armes chimiques et
dressé aux efforts même au reste sur la
scène internationale et c'est aussi une
façon d'envoyer un signal à la chine qui
maintient sa position de neutralité
embiez ambiguë et pour pour qu'elle même
puissent endosser un petit peu cette
ligne rouge la faire basculer on va le
pardon vous interrompre nos jours paris
de la chine et je vous propose
d'entendre un autre extrait d' du
discours du secrétaire général de l'otan
jens stoltenberg sur la chine justement
joined score et pékin s'est joint à
moscou pour remettre en question le
droit des nations indépendantes à
choisir leur propre voie
[Musique]
la chine a fourni à la russie un soutien
politique notamment en diffusant les
mensonges flagrants en faisant de la
désinformation et les alliés craignent
que la chine ne fournissent un soutien
matériel à l'invasion russe
fabrique peut-on dire précisément du
soutien chinois
[Applaudissements]
quelle forme 30 ils allumèrent poutine
au jour
est-ce que vous d'ailleurs vous employer
ce mot de soutien
le soutien qu'apporte la chine et le
soutien qui sert ses intérêts donc la
défense de la souveraineté d'un pays des
frontières d'un pays derrière ça on
n'entend évidemment l'objectif chinois
de maintenir sa politique de une seule
chine vis-à-vis vis-à-vis de taïwan le
soutien humanitaire
la chine le garantis en revanche
maintenant toute la question il n'y a
pas de condamnation évidente mais
maintenant la question c'est les formes
d' aide économique éventuellement ce que
l'on risque parce que l'on craint c'est
éventuellement un soutien soit d'armes
militaires fournis à la russie soit même
de pièces détachées parce que tout le
problème de la russie aujourd'hui aussi
c'est d'assurer ses approvisionnements
en pièces détachées qui font fonctionner
son armée et auquel on n'a plus accès
oui du côté du côté occidental on le
craint on n'en a pas la preuve on en a
pas la preuve encore sur le
sur la question des armements militaires
maintenant on voit que sur le terrain
économique la chine ne se tâte le
gouvernement chinois a incité ces
entreprises à occuper la place en russie
là où les entreprises occidentales se
retirer et les entreprises chinoises
sont encore assez prudente parce qu'il
ya toute la question des sanctions
secondaires qui pourraient être
concernées toutes les entreprises
chinoises qui chercheraient à contourner
les sanctions notamment américaines
puisque les états unis ont ce ce bras
armé institutionnels d'extra
territorialité qui leur permet de fait
d'imposer des amendes et des sanctions
judy et judiciaire hélas les entreprises
sont encore relativement frileuse
christian makarian autre prisme
occidental nous donne parfois
l'impression que le monde entier est
contre poutine c'est loin d'être le cas
il faut le rappeler il ya la chine y
avait des sites et l'inde le venezuela
cuba le brésil enfin bref il ya une
liste longue de pays qui soit ne disent
rien soit n'ont pas condamné
soissons se situe dans une ambiguïté
totain comme la turquie qui achètent des
missiles sks 400 à la russie tout en
étant membre de l'otan il ya aussi cette
attitude là non ce qui se pose
fondamentalement c'est que pour la
russie pour la chine il ya tout de même
un axe très fort qui s'est construit
celle axes de ce qu'on appelle
maintenant le poste occident ces pays
que ce soit pékin moscou envisagent une
sorte de leadership naturel de la
période qui s'ouvre selon re à partir de
maintenant puisque il considère que
l'occident n'a plus d'emprise sur le
reste du monde que les normes
occidentales ne sont plus celles qui
définissent l'absolu l'alpha et l'oméga
comme c'était le cas il ya une
cinquantaine d'années donc cette ère
post occidental pékin entend bel et bien
y jouer son rôle avec la russie là étant
la superpuissance économique et l'autre
la superpuissance militaire du moins
jusque là c'est pourquoi le conflit de
l'ukraine est extrêmement important s'il
était remporté de façon franche et nette
par la russie ça signifierait quand même
1 4 mais s'il ne l'est pas comme
beaucoup de signes semblent le montrer
alors il y aura une toute autre est un
qui s'ouvrira encore une intermédiaire
et c'est la raison pour laquelle pour
répondre à votre question de tout à
l'heure thomas parce que j'ai senti que
vous étiez quand même passionné et
indignes à juste titre par tout ce que
subit le peuple ukrainien il ya quand
même une étape diplomatique qui fois
qu'il faut conserver qui doit rester
dans le savoir-faire le mode de vie la
civilisation occidentale qui est la
désescalade donc maintenant à mon humble
avis il faut essayer de faire baisser la
tension parce que tant que vous
laisserez poutine choisir le niveau
d'intensité du conflit il n'ira plus
haut donc il faut maintenant essayer
d'aborder une perte de désescalade c'est
la raison pour laquelle on peut pas
s'impliquer trop ou plus avant dans des
opérations militaires et je crois qu'il
faut le comprendre j'entends cet
argument on va parler de l'union
européenne maintenant avec d'abord une
réaction d' emmanuel macron c'était tout
à l'heure juste après le sommet de
l'otan j'appelle qui avait trois sommets
aujourd'hui autant g7 et union
européenne et maquereau est revenu sur
la question de la dépendance énergétique
des 27
l'europe est là c'est une
caractéristique aussi naturel et notre
géographie et le plus grand acheteur
de fossiles parce que nous ne sommes pas
producteurs
et donc nous avons cette dépendance en
particulier au gaz au pétrole charbon
russe notre souhait est évidemment de
d'abord maîtriser les prix pour nos
consommateurs nous y reviendrons tout à
l'heure en conseil européen mais de très
vite diversifiée et pour moins dépendre
et ne pas être soumis à des mesures de
représailles mais surtout nous mêmes
réduire
les éléments
d'achat qui aujourd'hui vont vers la
russie
et on va faire tout de suite un peu de
pédagogie grâce à fanny fanny conquis
pour parler de la stratégie énergétique
de l'europe rebond soir fanny au rebond
soir un objectif on a entendu c'est de
réduire la dépendance au nez aux
énergies et le russe est l'enjeu est
énorme plus de 40% du gaz et 27 % du
pétrole importé dans l'union proviennent
de russie cette situation cache
cependant des disparités fortes entre
pays européens les importations venues
de russie représente par exemple 65 % de
la consommation de gaz en allemagne 29%
pour l'italie et 19% pour la france
alors en termes de calendrier à l'europe
annoncé le 8 mars dernier vouloir
réduire de deux tiers les importations
de gaz russe de l'union dès cette année
tandis qu'au même moment du côté des
états unis et bien joe biden annoncé
l'arrêt immédiat des importations de
pétrole depuis la russie il faut dire
que le pétrole russe représente
seulement 8% des importations
américaines l'enjeu n'est donc pas le
même taux que oui évidemment
concrètement quelles sont les pistes
évoquées pour réduire cette dépendance
en europe alors la commission européenne
appelle à diversifier les fournisseurs
et les routes d'approvisionnement en
misant davantage par exemple sur le
biogaz le gaz naturel liquéfié ou encore
l'hydrogène en termes de producteurs de
partenaires là aussi il va falloir se
tourner vers d'autres pays les états
unis la norvège l'algérie ou encore le
qatar la commission plaide également
pour un renforcement des règles de
stockage de gaz pour chaque pays par
exemple des obligations minimales et un
calendrier de remplissage une des pistes
également pour les vingt-sept et bien
c'est d'acheter du gaz en commun cela a
été fait on l'a vu avec les vaccins
contre le colis dont s'en souvient en
négociant ensemble idée bien sûr c'est
d'être plus fort et d'obtenir des tarifs
plus avantageux par ailleurs dans le
cadre sachet de 1 dans le cadre du plan
climat 2030 et bien la commission
européenne appelle accélérer les
investissements dans les énergies
renouvables à accélérer les efforts pour
décarbonés les bâtiments l'isolation les
modes de chauffage mais aussi dans
l'industrie et donc et bien selon
l'exécutif européen les mesures prises
hantée peuvent réduire la demande
européenne de gaz russe de deux tiers
d'ici la fin de l'année et rendre
l'union indépendant des hydrocarbures
russes bien avant 2030 merci fanny pour
pour ces détails est ce que vous y
croyez elvire fabry est ce que ça me
semble réaliste cet objectif de
réduction des deux tiers d'ici la fin de
cette année j'ai envie de dire c'était
déjà la voie que s'était donné les
européens d'une certaine façon en termes
de diversification enfin re de
transformation du mix énergétique pour
atteindre les objectifs de réduction de
l'empreinte carbone
maintenant là on a un impératif de court
terme on doit il s'agit de regagner
notre indépendance par rapport à un
volume de 155 milliards de mètres cubes
de gaz pour ne prendre que le cas il ya
des mesures de court terme qui peuvent
déjà
être prises directement réseau dé
diminuer la consommation en baissant de
chauffage ses 10000 ces 10 milliards de
mètres cubes qui sont qui sont chiffrées
il ya beaucoup de français qui l'ont
déjà fait il ya déjà beaucoup de soin
oui oui absolument mais je vais encore
quelque chose oui mais je pense que
c'est encore quelque chose qui pourrait
être davantage renforcée ensuite il est
évident que la première mesure qui
aurait le plus d'effet c'est l'enjeu de
la diversification et là il ya un actif
travail diplomatique est engagée pour se
tourner vers le qatar vers l'algérie au
delà des pays avec lesquels c'est plus
évident etats unis canada et la joe
biden vient de prendre des engagements
sur des exportations plus importantes de
gaz liquéfié et le canada sur des
importations et exportations plus
importantes de pétrole s'est également
de la journée également absolument
maintenant il s'agit de voir de se
tourner vers d'autres pays qui sont eux
mêmes très sollicités puisque tous les
problèmes de tension que l'on a sur les
marchés mondiaux actuellement alors
c'est davantage vrai pour le pétrole où
ça peut davantage et distribuer à
travers le monde pour le gaz c'est déjà
plus compliqué mais cette
diversification elle est essentielle et
puis ensuite il ya ces postes qui
concerne les équipements on est en
éolien solaire c'est mais c'est des
investissements des docteurs qui bien
sûr ce de temps à court terme on va
terminer là dessus christian le gal
parce que vous l'avez ok mais sans
rentrer dans le détail sur le monde et
sur le sommet de l'union les failles les
petites lignes de fractures dont dont
vous parliez c'est quoi c'est qui sait
quel pays la hongrie peut-être celui
dont on peut parler en premier alors sur
la question des sanctions on avait une
une assez belle unanimité avant que
monsieur sorbonne effectivement fasse
une déclaration
disant qu'il allait peut-être lever les
sanctions à l'égard de la russie ce qui
a d'ailleurs amené une réaction très
vive à varsovie donc l'amour entre
monsieur k chine ce qui est monsieur or
ban est un peu est un peu compromis donc
ça c'est un premier point deuxième point
c'est la question effectivement de se
coordonner comme le disait elvire pour
pour les achats si vous voulez c'est un
point très important d'éviter que chaque
pays à y faire son petit marché et en
les allemands eu un peu tendance à a
commencé à faire ça en allant voir le le
qatar je crois que l'europe a intérêt à
ceux à se coordonner pour faire une
politique d'achat qu'ils soient
mutualisés et puis le troisième point
c'est le prix
et là sur le prix
de l'énergie pour le consommateur on
voit qu'il ya un clivage jusqu'à une
proposition française sur un prix seuil
le président en a parlé dans sa
conférence de presse mais quand lorsque
vous regardez qui soutient cette
proposition ce sont essentiellement les
pays du sud l'espagne le portugal les
pays du nord qui sont plutôt dans une
tradition de libre-échange n'aime pas
assez idée de prix fixé donc là on a un
vrai on a un vrai clivage qui rejoint
d'ailleurs le vieux clivage entre les
fruits est exactement où entre les
protectionnistes les libéraux est aussi
ça se recoupent merci beaucoup merci à
tous d'avoir participé à ce débat ici en
plateau ou en duplex merci christian de
nous avoir répondu favorablement à la
toute dernière minute
voilà je vous dis à à lundi pour un
autre numéro deux sens public merci
laetitia on se retrouve à mardi prochain